quand j'ai embrassé un acteur dans un
film c'est pas forcément logique sur
milan ac à 8 heures du matin acquis et
ses 7 ans problème yvan
toute la journée que je mettrais me fait
mal au ventre de maux de tête pendentif
il a extrapolé tous les
poètes ou les traits sont exagérées
alors il s'est fait un personnage de
jaloux mais enfin plus que jaloux il
faut sauver sa question que je fasse il
me donne ses vingt cinq mois
avant l'épreuve mais non vivant avec une
actrice c'est un truc de fou dans une
comédie dans la vraie vie c'est pas tant
un truc de fou en tout cas pour moi il
ya certaines personnes qui souffrent
probablement d'avoir vécu et des
actrices mais à partir du moment où
beaucoup on s'en va quand même
sur ce match sauf que pour un con j'en
ai vu des films
avec quel tournant
j'ai pas couché avec moi je la connais
comme ça je note enfin
elle et elle est belle et épanouie
et parce qu'elle vit avec un homme qu'il
arrive il y avait les filets elle
s'épanouit on va dire c'est pas chez
kana strub à la poêle dans le flou tu
vois juste ça juste le fait que tout le
monde puisse avoir pour elle ça c'est
pas faux ça c'est vraiment elle
s'attache technologies c'est vraiment
son film ça lui ressemble c'est c'est
son écriture fait sa patte c'est son
originalité à lui moi je fais un outil
tu veux que je te dis
perso
j'y mets tout
je crois que c'est facile allez-y comme
si c'était difficile je me ferais bien
payé pour embrasser des gonzesses